[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for this
intimate gathering.
So for those of you who don't
know me, I'm Kendra Donahue,
and I am a sales
manager in LCS, looking
after Africa and Israel.
I also work very closely with
the Africa Googler Network,
so absolutely delighted to have
Andrew Fairbairn joining us
today.
So he's the founder of Sponsors
for Educational Opportunity,
which is a charity
that helps students,
top talented students,
from ethnic backgrounds
and underprivileged backgrounds
get into great careers
both in business, and
technology, et cetera,
so places like Google ideally.
And he's been with
them for 17 years,
having gone through the program
himself and worked with a SEO
in the US.
So he's now based
in the UK, and we're
delighted to have him here
talking to us about how
we can make inclusion real.
So over to you, Andrew.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: So
thank you for having me.
I like to talk.
I talk a lot.
I put this together sort of
specifically for you guys.
It's a bit of a cobbling
together of a variety
of different themes.
So I may not be as practiced
with this particular slide deck
as I might be.
But my name is, again,
Andrew Fairbairn.
I'm blessed really
to be the founder
of this organization in London.
I went through an earlier
iteration of it in 1995.
I got my first exposure
to the high end sort
of professional services
world, with an internship
through SEO at Lehman
Brothers way back then.
It opened my eyes to what was
possible for me personally,
and it essentially changed
my life in that sense.
I wasn't coming down some
terrible path where I
was on my way to rack and ruin.
But it was one of those things
where nobody in my family
had ever been a banker, or
a consultant, or a lawyer,
or any of those sorts
of hot shot professions,
never mind software programmer,
but this remember is 1995,
so it was a different
era in software too.
I am-- you know,
I came to London
a few years after that
experience and started it here.
So I'll get into
some of the history
of the program along the way.
The number one thing, I'm
really pleased to be here
and really glad to have interest
in what we're talking about.
So here we go.
I don't have a clicker.
AUDIENCE: Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN:
You'll be my man.
All right, beautiful,
thank you, sir.
So SEO London is,
as you say, it's
an organization dedicated to
trying to find opportunities
for people who have all
the potential and all
of the ability, but don't by
virtue of their circumstance
necessarily have all the access.
It's kind of that simple.
And so, you know, there are
a variety of different areas
where we focus on,
but predominantly
we're looking for people
who are historically
under-represented
in a given industry.
We're looking for people who
are coming up the hard way.
And that can be
really any ethnicity
at the end of the day.
If someone's really
needs a leg up,
we want to be there for them.
And the way we sort have
grown over the years,
we have programs for secondary
schoolers, years 11 to 13.
So if you're a
15-year-old, and you know,
you're not sure up from down,
which most 15-year-olds don't,
certainly I didn't,
you need some guidance.
And so we provide a
multi-industry work experience,
where you imagine a
15-year-old going and doing
a work experience at an ad
agency, and then an investment
bank, and then a corporate law
firm, and then an engineering
firm, and perhaps
even Google, they then
come out of that
experience by the time
you're 13 knowing a lot
about a lot of stuff
and knowing why they
might want to follow
a particular path or not.
And we layer that with all sorts
of mentoring, and training,
and life skills, and so on to
ensure that the students are
actually rock stars, super
ninjas we call them by the time
they get to university.
We don't force them down a
university path to be clear.
They can go on apprenticeships,
underwater basket weaving.
Whatever we want
to do, that's cool.
We just want to make sure
that they have awareness
of all the different things
they could be doing if they so
chose to follow the path.
The careers program is all
about university students.
It's simple enough to define,
but we look for talent
everywhere.
So we are currently, I think
we have over 5,000 applications
in the queue right now.
And we've been on
campus for just a month.
For us, that's sort of a
record actually for the scale
of the operation we work with.
We've got 750 students going
through that program every year
across multiple
industries, and we'll
put up the obligatory
logo slide later so you'll
see what that's about.
But you know, there again,
it's about exposure.
It's about experience.
It's about life skills on
top of the technical skills
to grow and thrive.
We work with Google
in this space
right now as people are at the
end of their university career
crossing over into
sort of graduate,
and so we work with the
sales marketing team there.
It's been a great
little relationship.
SEO Connect is our museum store
within the museum in so far
as that's actually a
for-profit entity that we--
it's a tiny piece of our overall
operation, to be to be clear.
But it is where we try and-- we
have a jobs board for instance,
where we have people
coming on board there,
and it looks, and smells, and
feels like any old jobs board
that you might imagine.
But we also, through
that program,
run a lot of different events.
So I was just
mentioning earlier we're
going to be running an event on
venture capital, for instance.
There's a difference--
a lot of the folks who
come through our programs,
and over the years,
we have thousands upon thousands
of alumni, a lot of them
are sort of highly trained,
highly professional, highly
motivated type A
personalities who
are interested in
doing other things.
And access to VC knowledge would
be something really interesting
for them.
So we run that through the
Connect end of our work.
If you could click the
button once, all of that
wouldn't really
differentiate us in many ways
from a lot of
other organizations
in the world except that
this particular line is
a real-- it's an SEO mantra.
It's not about you.
It's about the people
who come after you.
That suffuses everything we do.
So no decision gets made without
that being sort of part of it.
You know, I got into SEO
in '95, because of people
who came before me, sort
of broke ground and made
possible my presence in that
rarefied world of Wall Street.
When people come
through our doors today,
they're essentially
creating relationship space,
relationship capital,
where if they're
able to prove their abilities
in a difficult, competitive work
environment in an elite setting,
that opens the doors for others
to come behind them.
And an example, it
wouldn't have been
so long ago that imagine you're
in a Wall Street setting.
You're on a trading
floor, and there's
a billion dollar
pound euro block
trade that's going through.
The thing has to be sold.
It's got to be sold
fast, and it has--
who on that desk is going to
get the bulk of that order.
That's the problem to solve
for the manager of the desk.
They look around and
they say, who do I trust?
Who I do I know is
going to get this done.
And boom, if that person was
black, or Muslim, or Asian not
too long ago, the
odds that they were
going to get that opportunity
to execute that black trade
would have been
smaller than otherwise.
The world is changing.
The world has changed.
We can be very grateful for
all that's occurring around us,
but we want to be able to ensure
that we have excellent people
in place well-trained--
trained to not just survive in
these environments, but thrive.
And if we've done our job well,
the next time that block trade
or that big project
whatever comes up,
it's going to be fair play
to everyone in the room,
because everyone is shown to
have proven their worth, proven
their ability, and if
we've done our job well,
we'll have been a part of that
success and that training.
You want jump in here?
We have a virtuous cycle.
We go out and take
sponsorship donations
from large corporates
like a Google.
And we go into the
world and we go to all
the different universities.
We bring together
an applicant pool.
We screen them.
We scrub them.
They sort them.
We sift system.
We decide who do we think
in this group can most
benefit from our help,
but also, if we help them,
will go really, really far?
And those are sort
of the two drivers.
And who do we think
if we assist will
be able to then draw a
community behind them to sort
of really embed through their
hard work, dedication, success,
and applied talent you know,
a change for all concerned,
the firms that are
sponsoring them,
the people coming
in behind them.
So we find folks.
We try and create
lasting outcomes.
And again, it's not about you.
It's about the people
coming after you.
We want people to
be giving back.
I have no interest,
frankly, in working
with someone who thinks that
they're going to make it--
it's all about them.
It's all about
their own success,
and they're master
of their own domain.
Useless.
That is not someone who's
going to help our organization
and our social mission.
If I was a recruiting
agency, and I just
wanted to get bums in seats
and take a commission,
maybe I would do that.
But I have no time
for that in my world.
That permits the potential
of a virtuous cycle to occur.
We just had a milestone
last year actually,
a really, really
cool milestone, where
a woman from our very
first class in 2000
made partner of Goldman
Sachs, and I mean,
that's the top-- she's
at the top of her game.
And she's on our board now,
and she she's giving back,
and she's sort of-- she's
leading the way for others.
I got a call from
a guy, who said,
hey, do you know
Nishi over at Goldman,
I used to work with
her, and she had
a great relationship with SEO.
I'd like to bring
an SEO in my firm.
Can we talk?
And if I can advance a
couple more points, one more.
"I heard about you from."
It happens all the time.
Most of those 5,000
applications we had
came in before we got to
campus, word of mouth,
brothers, sisters, cousins,
nephews, relations.
We heard-- I interviewed
this fantastic candidate
the other day, who heard about
us from someone in Canada,
who heard about us from
someone in Nigeria, who
heard about us from someone.
It was sort of this global
network was all over the place.
We love that.
That is lifeblood, because that
means that we're actually--
the thesis that relationships
matter and getting in one
person--
we'll call it a spear
point of diversity,
if you like, permits, you know,
the thin end of the wedge.
It permits the fat end
of the wedge to actually
be embedded in an organization.
Likewise, it facilitates the
sort of alumni-driven network,
whether it's that alumni at
Goldman Sachs or other people
came right after her, you
know, if you go for instance,
to a Citibank right now, from
managing director level all
the way to entry
level analysts, we've
got dozens of people
who all understand this,
all understand when you're a
new person entering that sphere
that you have a
network to join into.
And that's really cool.
And that's really-- that
allows more pervasive culture
of diversity.
And I'll get to that
as we go further.
So this is the history lesson.
I enter the fray somewhere
about here just before 2000.
Way back in 1963,
this saint of a guy,
Mike Auschwitz set up
a program, you know,
the spirit of the '60s.
Kennedy I think was
still president,
to help kids from tough
high school backgrounds
get into universities,
focus on New York City.
Over the years, it was a very
successful program, but sort
of looking at the results a
number of years later in 1980,
it was determined
that these kids
were getting into university.
They were getting
great training.
But they weren't
getting the jobs.
They were getting jobs.
But we all know
there is a difference
between the jobs and just jobs.
And so a careers
program was founded,
and that's what I
participated in.
That was my ticket when
came out of university
and ended up at Lehman Brothers,
and that opened my eyes.
The scales fell, and I could see
the world in a whole new light,
and it was like, oh, my
gosh, if I do this and that,
I could accomplish a few things.
I ended up working at
UBS, then Deutsche Bank
in a variety of different
functions, transactional
and strategy jobs.
And I was here--
here, I was in London, sorry--
this morning I was in London.
Looking out on the trading
floor of the equity sales team
could have used some
diversity shall we say.
The corporate finance
equity research departments
could have used some diversity.
So I approached the head
of training and development
said, hey, can we do
this, this SEO thing?
I mean, it's pretty good.
I was smiled at, but
ultimately supported.
I had one awkward
conversation with a fellow
who ran a recruiting for
a major investment bank.
He sort of essentially
metaphorically
patted me on the
head and said, that's
a really nice American concept
that you're bringing to the UK.
You know, we don't have a
race problem in this country.
We have a class
problem, which anyway--
anyway, so we took off
on the back of a pilot,
on my credit card.
We were able to get a
successful pilot program going,
and then dotbomb occurred.
I was doing sort
of, at that point,
sort of fintech 1.0
venture investing
on the bank's balance sheet
as Pets.com was crashing.
It was a messy time.
I ended up going
back to New York,
and much of the rest of
my involvement over time
has been on the board.
I've only recently come back
in the last year to assist.
But while I was doing my
two or three other careers,
alumni from The New York
program launched in China--
Hong Kong and Shanghai,
then in Saigon, Ho Chi Minh,
we have a SEO Vietnam.
We launched a scholars program.
Just as in New
York, they started
with secondary schoolers and
went to sort of university,
we started with the university,
and we were doing so well.
We were seeing such great growth
and such a robust response
from the community that we
started our scholars program.
We were backwards.
And we've since then launched
our Connect Program, which
I described earlier, and
we have a program in Accra,
in Ghana, which is actively
looking at Lagos in Nigeria
as a potential expansion point.
It goes on.
I've been involved in
discussions about SEO Bogota.
SEO Rio and Sao Paolo.
And one of our staffers
is from Afghanistan.
He was going back to Kabul.
I was only half
joking when I said,
we should be talking
about SEO Kabul, man,
because it's a universal
concept that there
are those who have access and
those that do not have access.
And it is, to my mind,
is a clear statement
to say that there is money
being left on the table
with everyone's not involved.
And so my sense is that we have
an opportunity to do more here.
Can we flip?
Back here, it's
important to note,
like, you couldn't find
a diversity officer
in the city of London in 2000.
Maybe someone cared about
it, a few management
consultants floating
around talking about it.
There's maybe one organization
that I could identify back
then called the Windsor Fellows
that was doing some work on it
in a serious capacity.
Now, it's an industry.
There are dozens
of organizations
that attempt to
promote diversity
in some way, shape, or form.
And in many ways, you
could call it a golden age
for diversity and inclusion.
The phones are ringing
off-- every week,
I get one or two calls from
some organization looking
to learn more about what
we do because they're
trying to embed more
diversity and inclusiveness
in their culture.
That's fantastic.
That's absolutely fantastic.
I'm here.
You guys are talking about it.
We're in a really
interesting place.
I just sort of sit back
and do a little victory
dance every time I hear about
some new program that's coming
up, because we're a charity.
No one is getting
rich off of this.
What we care about
is the social change,
the long term impact of this.
And we see that
happening all around us.
The city of London today, and
we should talk about Dublin,
because I don't know much
about what's going on
in Dublin in diversity.
The city of London is
radically different, completely
different than
what it was before.
There's still lots of
people trying to clambering
and getting into jobs.
Lots of ground
still yet to cover.
But let me tell you, 2000,
this wasn't even a thing.
So shall we?
So the obligatory logo slide.
And here you guys are.
And you should know in banking
and corporate finance Wall
Street terms, up
and to the left is
the premier spot where you could
possibly be on any slide deck.
So if I'm presenting to
a corporate law firm,
there may be some adjustment
of slides and logos.
But you are in the
prime spot today, guys.
So we started with banking.
We've seen a surge of interest
in asset management firms
in the last year.
I mean, like it's night and day.
It's really remarkable to
see what's been occurring.
Law firms have been focused
on this for a number of years.
And we have sort of
a hodgepodge of firms
that come in and out
of our consulting
corporate and technology world.
These programs
are deeply mature.
They are deeply at scale.
We've been doing it
for a very long time.
Corporate technology firms
tend to be very different one
to the other.
And so you have different
sort of strategies
for dealing with them.
The engineering program is a
fantastic program at the Royal
Academy, where we're training
up young people from typically
less-sought-after universities.
In the UK, you describe them
as the post '92 universities,
polytechnics that became
universities not so long ago.
And that's just driving
some great results as well.
So anyway, lots of flashy logos.
You're in the top left.
That's the take away.
All right, so we can
shift gears a little bit.
So diversity as a whole,
it's a lot of things.
We tend to focus on these three.
I sort of refer to
ethnicity, ethnic diversity,
gender diversity, and
social mobility diversity
as the big three.
Disability, LGBT, we
are deep supporters
and in love with
anyone who is going
to sort of work on that front.
We have all the
empathy in the world.
We just don't have scale.
And I think at Google
you know about scale.
To be effective, we
want to be able to help
as many people as possible, and
we need the systems to do it.
We have the systems here.
So that being said, I was
going to throw the question
to you guys.
I mean, I don't
know what, you know,
not so long ago, I
became 39 forever.
You know, there's a--
I had an interest
in [INAUDIBLE]..
We were at a consulting
firm, and we're
having sort of a
lunch and learn.
We sat in this kind
of a discussion
about what is difference
in that context?
And this woman raised her hand.
She said, you know, I don't
fit into the classic diversity
categories that you
were searching for.
But I feel really left
out in a lot of instances,
because I'm not--
I didn't come in with
that original class.
Certain firms, you
come in, you're marked.
You started as a
graduate, as a first year,
and you work your way
up through the system.
You have a certain set of common
attributes and experiences
that come from that.
If you come as an
experienced hire,
you're coming in as you
don't have that network.
You don't have-- you
don't have that stamp.
And so lateral hires then.
That's an interest-- I mean,
it's something to consider.
We're talking about
difference here.
Refugees.
We're meeting with
a group that focuses
on this issue in particular,
they have a different approach.
They need to have a
different approach.
And I don't feel
anybody can help
the people who like Marmite.
But that's another
thing entirely.
So can I ask, what is-- is
there a diversity officer
in the room or someone who's
deeply embedded in that world
here?
OK.
Do these categories
resonate here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: Yeah.
Does this one
resonate particularly?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN:
So great moment,
the value of diversity at work.
I was going to bring a
PowerPoint presentation
before I was laughed at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: And
now I have to know-- now,
I clearly have to learn how
to port all of my PowerPoint,
which I've built my whole life
and career into Google Sheets
or slides.
There it is.
Anyway, so you should
discriminate against me,
or train me, or teach me.
It would be better yet, right?
Can I see one more
slide up here?
So that's sort of the
meta-picture, if you like.
But you know, it's interesting.
We have conversations
about diversity
in all sorts of different
places, and it shifts it moves.
You know, I had Switzerland.
What does diversity
mean in Switzerland?
Does anyone have any idea what
diversity means in Switzerland?
What would you
expect it to mean?
AUDIENCE: To be
a Swiss national.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: To
be a Swiss national.
I mean, isn't that--
I wouldn't have-- that would
not have been my first answer
upon going after it.
In Brazil, whole
other set of dynamics.
There's north, there's
south, there is urban, rural,
there's any manner
of things going on.
In China, SEO staff leading
that effort, who are all
doing this on a
volunteer basis, were
challenged by Chinese
students saying,
is this some sort of CIA thing?
Because this is free, and
you're giving us this access.
You're American.
What's going on here?
It's really a program for
sort of aspiring young Chinese
students who don't
have the access
to get into these top jobs.
It's a 95% Han
Chinese community.
It's not like ethnicity
was the driver.
And yet you have
this whole other set
of issues where
people are worrying
about political
intrigue instead of just
getting the opportunity.
It's OK.
We can go ahead.
Actually, why don't we--
why don't we push one more
one more button and
see what happens.
One more time.
So you know, one of
the interesting things
about the conversations
on diversity
is that when we started,
most of our focus
was on ethnic diversity.
Over time, that fellow who was
sort of patting me on the head
and said, you know, we have a
class issue in this country.
You know, a report came
out not so long ago
in the UK, Social
Mobility Commission, one
or two grantees
attached to it I'm sure,
saying that for the
first time in the history
of-- in the measured
history of race relations
and social mobility in the
UK, poor, white, working class
males were the number one
sort of disadvantaged group
in the UK.
And we live in an age of, you
know, stay away from politics,
but when you think about
the rise of a Trump,
the rise of a Brexit
focus, a lot of folks
have been left behind in
the UK, who are white,
working class, and
in a ethnic diversity
definition of diversity,
are being ignored.
And so at SEO, we spend
a ton of time on Fariha,
and we spend a ton of
time on Billy as well,
because it's just necessary
to reflect in the community.
Essentially, they
are great people
with great talent, great
performance, but you know,
they're up against
different challenges.
You know, Fariha,
maybe she's Muslim,
and you know, by virtue
of that is culturally not
permitted to shake
someone's hand--
a man's hand, who is not
in her immediate family.
I mean, maybe she wants
to pray five times a day
in the middle of a training
program to get into a law firm.
That's very-- if you're
not expecting it,
you're not looking
for it, you don't
know what it is to
observe her doing this,
that can throw you for a loop.
Billy may have the wrong accent.
Billy may have the
wrong references.
Billy may support the
wrong football team.
There's a whole
range of other things
that can get in
the way of a Billy,
just as they might
with a Fariha.
They have different challenges,
but conceptually, we're
talking about difference.
We're talking about acceptance.
We're talking about
maximizing the pool of talent
available to a given firm.
And in that case, we
see a need for what
we do all across the map.
So every firm we work
with is really focused
on entry-level
graduate recruitment,
because it's obvious.
It's like we need, we can find.
And it's essentially recruitment
in the talent attraction
and selection business as such.
It has really
become a commodity.
There are lots of organizations
out there seeking to do that.
We had one-- one huge
investment bank come to us
and say, we don't need
you guys for attraction,
because we get hundreds of
thousands of applications
every year from all
sorts of people.
But no one trains
them like you do.
And so we see this as the sort
of kind of the easy part of it.
Getting out to universities,
getting people to apply,
screening people,
straightforward
manipulation of a spreadsheet
much of the time--
a deeper assessment
about personal traits,
qualifications, and so on.
And finally, this
is the easy part.
And one more, please.
Retention is really
where I see the future
of all of this working out.
If you've gone out and
recruited, you know,
year after year there is this
great, wonderful recruiting
budget, a whole bunch of
new and different faces,
that's wonderful.
But if they're all sort
of veering off one,
to two, to three years into the
mix, it wastes a lot of money,
frankly.
Now, we can talk about
the millennial generation
and people who want to be in a
place for two or three years,
and they want to move on, and
that's just the new, you know,
gig culture inside corporates.
But fundamentally, I
would like to think
that a Googler, if they spend
a little more time at Google,
retain more and more
institutional memory,
are able to sort of
scale their own networks
and their own social capital
with benefit to others
internally.
If you've got a bunch
of people who have only
been there for
two years, where's
the institutional knowledge?
Where is the
institutional memory?
Where is the scalability?
And so a couple of
observations here.
Maybe we need to
be measuring this.
How do you measure it?
Very few people
are measuring it.
It's like this-- it's like
the next obvious point.
But I don't know
anyone, frankly,
any firm that we work with that
is aggressively measuring this,
because it's sensitive.
It's politically
fraught with peril,
if you're going to ask
people to be tracking people.
In Europe, in some
jurisdictions, it's illegal.
In France, you know, they prefer
to stick their head in the sand
and not deal with the
issue, and have it
bubble up all around them, then
actually deal with it head on.
And I think a lot of
places are like that.
So another element of this
is promotion, which is,
who gets promoted?
I used that example earlier,
sort of the billion dollar
pound euro block trade.
Who's getting the opportunity
to do the cool work?
I don't know what that
would be in this context.
But who's getting
the opportunity
to actually make a difference
such that they can get
promoted.
There was a recent--
I chatted with a guy who's
at a law firm, major, major,
law firm, who had gone through
a restructuring, a fairly
dramatic restructuring, and a
lot of people were laid off.
And this individual, who
is a black man, said to me,
you know, he didn't
believe that there
was racism or discrimination
going on as such in the fact
that seven out of eight sort of
black associates were laid off.
He said he didn't think
that was the issue.
He said, they were generally
less qualified, less important
to the business.
But the question was,
who was staffing them
so they actually could
become important to business?
And that resonates
with me, because I
think a lot of what
we find around us
and a lot of the issues that we
see, and we'll get to it in one
of the last pages, is around
this notion of giving people
an opportunity to
succeed and promotion,
build that internal, social,
professional capital.
Commitment.
So two simple observations, I
don't know how many of you--
if there is a lot of turnover
in organizations at large, HR
departments, especially
the graduate recruitment
departments, they flip
like nobody's business.
It's unbelievable how fast--
how many times we have to change
our--
we'll come back and
communicate, and recommunicate,
and overcommunicate what we
do to a new generation of HR
professionals.
So people are always moving, and
that's sort of a fact of life.
But that's not just for
the recruitment folks.
That's all up and
down the organization.
So people who you have
support for this premise
in the organization
will know, and who's
going to replace them?
So the firm has to be
committed, and if you
don't have people in the
executive suite on board,
forget about it.
Frankly, it's just
window dressing.
You need to have people occupied
at the very senior levels.
I'm really pleased to say
at a place like, you know,
Aberdeen Asset Management,
obviously has recently
gone through a merger,
their CEO came and spoke
to our candidates.
That's a big deal.
And one of the
interesting things that's
occurred over time
is that way back
in the day, 2000 in my
case, you had a situation
where diversity was new.
People didn't know
what to do with it.
And so it became
in terms of dealing
with it as a strategic
priority of an organization,
it went all the way to
the top, because there's
no one in the middle to sort of
figure out what to do with it.
And over time, the
bigger firms have really
embedded diversity into what
they're trying to accomplish.
But it means that the
eye is off the ball
in many respects
for many big firms
from what's happening in
sort of diversity intake
and management, because it's
been pushed down so many levels
where we see--
so what I'm trying to say
is without that support,
you start to get drift.
You start to have conversations,
really unfortunate
conversations.
I had this one.
I'm paraphrasing slightly,
but major consulting firm
who shall not be
named called and said,
you know, essentially, Andrew,
we need five black people.
I need them in the
next two months,
and I'll pay you 2,000 a head.
That's the conversation
that you get
when the senior folks
aren't paying attention,
because it's been devolved
so far down the chain
it's just somebody who's got
a bums on seats mentality,
and that's all they're
trying to accomplish.
So my response was, no, we
can't do that, by the way.
We could, but we
don't want to do that.
That's not the discussion that
we want to get engaged in.
OK, so-- a series of
tiles will pop up,
and each one sort of
leads to the other
and sort of tracks the
evolution of what we've seen
in London in the last 17 years.
So I'm going to be
nudging you a little bit.
So does anyone at Google
feel there isn't a diversity
problem?
Is sort of acknowledged that--
AUDIENCE: People exist.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: People exist.
People exist.
Well, I think that's-- and
that's hat you tend to see
as you go forward
through the tiles.
There's always someone
who is one, or two,
or three tiles behind, always.
So we get from
denial to acceptance,
and then eventually you get a
sense across the industry, what
we've seen occurs, a lot
of different, underfunded
groups sort of pop
up saying, we've
got to do something about this.
And you know, but
it's my part-time job,
and I have 10
other things to do,
and my budget is 1,200 pounds.
Can you help me?
So you get this sort of--
a lot of underweight efforts.
Through all that,
a handful of firms
emerge as being really
committed and really
sort of showing they know
what needs to get done.
And that's an exciting
moment, because you
start to see sort of
people taking ahead--
leading the pack.
And soon enough,
because HR folks
have all sorts of
conferences that they go to,
and they start
talking about what
they're doing at this firm,
what they're doing at that firm.
No one admits that
anyone has a problem,
but there's the cool
things they're doing.
We see best practices in
air quotes coming along,
because that's--
it's the solidification of some
of the early experiments that
starts to occur.
Can we go ahead?
And suddenly, and it's
really-- it's really-- like,
I'm on LinkedIn, and I've just--
there's like
diversity awards this,
and there's diversity
expert this, and everyone's
a diversity speaker or not.
And so it's really--
it's fun to watch.
I mean, it's everywhere.
And these are folks who
are now at the cutting
edge of sort of some of
the early experiments.
And like I said, there's always
someone who's still back here
and someone who's
like, yeah, OK,
but I don't what to do about it.
Yeah, well, I don't have a
lot of time or money for this.
But we're certainly at
a point in many places
today where there's
experts everywhere.
And so I think
right now, diversity
has become very
mainstream, and as I said,
there are people still
at the very beginning
of the first tile.
But it's an exciting
time, because there are--
another firm we worked,
they hired a slate of--
I think it was six new
entrants into their firm
for a particular division
in a particular role,
all white, male from Oxbridge.
I'm sure they're all
perfectly well talented,
but one of the leaders on
that team was a senior woman,
and she was furious
that you know,
her business, which was
built around working
with female
entrepreneurs was not
going to be supported
by-- if that
was going to be the status
quo, that was not helping her
in her business.
So you have people all up
and down sort of a spectrum
that you see movement.
And so that firm will then come
to an SEO London or some group
that might be something like us
and say, how can we help that?
The next year, by the
way, apparently there
was six women who were hired.
So it was yin and yang came
on, and hopefully, now it's
more three and three, and
fours, and twos at this stage.
Keep going.
And so, yeah, some industries
are back here-- certainly
in a few industries
we see, particularly
the law firms and
the investment banks,
it used to be that you'd
blindly go out in April
and try and recruit for
September of the same year,
and that was what was done.
Now, you know, we have a
secondary school program,
where firms are looking
to draw in pipeline talent
from that early on to
ensure that they have
the numbers in gross
form so by the time
it's whittled down to
their recruiting class,
that they have the people
they need and want.
So you know, we've
been living the war
for talent for a long time.
You guys, the
Googlers of the world,
are absolutely putting pressure
on all the big banks, and law
firms, and consulting
firms, because what
you do has a certain
je ne sais quoi,
it's so much more interesting
than prospectuses.
But you'll tell
me if that's true.
Maybe they've got it all wrong.
I don't know.
If you go to the next--
I talked about retention.
I think this is the next front.
I think people are starting
to wake up to this as they've
gone through.
They've done a bunch
of experiments.
They're trying to figure
out what's going on.
There are people who
can talk the talk.
Some people are
walking the walk.
And now they're
saying, well, sort of
like what occurred back with
Mike Auschwitz in New York,
you know, you're getting
kids into university, but not
necessarily into the jobs.
We're getting a lot of folks
in, but are they staying?
And that's the next evolutionary
step, one more step.
And so, yeah, this is--
I think of the whole
diversity and inclusion
agenda as something
that's totally solvable.
I mean, it just requires will.
It requires focus,
and the reality
is that big firms have a lot
of other things to focus on.
And I genuinely believe
that the people,
you know, our counterparts
at many of these firms
sincerely believe
in love and want
to sort of embrace and advance
the cause of diversity.
I really believe that.
There'll be a few exceptions
that you see come and go.
But I think most
of the people we
deal with on the other side
of the table sponsoring
our activities really
believe that they're
doing what they want to--
trying to accomplish
these goals.
But they're under budgeted.
They're understaffed.
And so they're forced into
this world where they're
being shouted out from above
to hit numbers, do this,
do that, the other, and they're
given a tiny budget to do it.
And so is the answer just
throw more money at it?
I don't know.
I think it's a
cultural question.
I don't think it
necessarily requires that.
If you start to figure this--
the firms start to
figure out retention.
A lot of the upfront
investment and experiments,
it solves itself.
And some firms have
figured it out,
but most are figuring it out.
OK, so each one of these topics
could be a book, an HBO mini
series, you name it.
But I figured I'd close on this.
As we go through this, we can
open up and have a little bit
more dialogue back and forth.
I think I know the
answer to this,
but how many people have heard
of the topic unconscious bias?
Everyone's heard of-- right.
It's everywhere.
I don't need to go into it.
I think the point
is that this is
on the lips of every
diversity inclusion group.
This is about as
mainstream as things get.
But you know, it's not
just I think about the bias
that we all face.
Try being a Rohingya Muslim
in Myanmar right about now.
Try being a South
Korean in Japan.
In Singapore, a
highly modern society,
is a lot of tribalism between
Chinese, Malay, and Indian
populations.
A lot of those
lines don't cross.
This is a global issue
I think in the West,
call it the US and
Western Europe,
there's a lot of very
positive work going on.
We should, I think,
as a society,
sort to be patting ourselves
on the back at some level
but just knowing
there's a hell of a lot
more work to be done, the
fact that there's movement
in the right direction.
It's really-- you get
racism, or sexism, or ageism,
and everything is just prejudice
gone wrong in a situation
where there's uneven power.
And power flips.
You know, my father,
who is a white guy,
was in Jamaica for many years.
And it was where I was raised
for much of my childhood.
And you know, a super
well-qualified guy,
PhD in this and that,
in his specialty,
experienced a lot of racism.
It's just he was in a
black dominant country
with a power base that
was not favoring him.
So it works both
ways is the reality.
My mother, who is
black, then, you
know, from Jamaica coming up
to Boston, experienced sort
of the flip side, it right?
So it goes both ways.
It's really where
is there imbalance.
So much of our work, whether
we want to call it unconscious
bias is dealing with power
dynamics, just making sure
there's as much
evenness as possible.
And you're never
going to get rid--
I mean, this whole Harvey
Weinstein thing in Hollywood
right now is all about power.
It's that simple.
It's going to happen.
It's never going away as long as
there are humans in the world,
but we can at least start
to address the power
dynamics and the opportunities.
So good enough expediency.
I think a lot of the
challenge we face
is just because
people are dealing
with what's good enough.
The story of C. I just want
to name my dear friend C.
You know, coming up at
Deutsche Bank years ago,
our team was growing fast.
And we needed to hire
someone really fast.
We needed someone really
good and really qualified,
so we went to the HR department
and said, we need someone fast,
and they sent over C.
And he was awesome.
He was so good.
He was like, the best
thing we could have had.
And then we went back, and the
team kept growing, and we said,
we need another person.
We need-- like, C,
who do you know?
And C went and found G.
And G came on board,
and he was fantastic.
He did everything.
He was a superstar.
He did everything
we needed to do.
Life was good.
We kept growing.
We went C, G, who'd you know?
They gave us T. And
then the thing about it
was, they were all Oxford
blues, sports players, you know,
white guys who are
super well-trained like.
They all did an amazing job.
And so, you know,
this is where I
think good enough really
drives a lot of things.
If you can hire the kid out of
Imperial, or Stanford, or MIT,
or whatever, and
they've this fit
the mold in a generic, quick
hit sense, why search harder?
Why expend the extra effort to--
if what you've got
is good enough.
I know, aging myself, there
was a Fatboy Slim album
a bunch of years ago that had
this big sort of lumpy guy
with a brown T-shirt said, I'm
number one, so why try harder?
You know, this is sort
of a lot of people--
you've got what you
need, so why try harder?
And so I think there's a
really interesting opportunity
for the firms that
really embrace
the notion of diversity,
to see the market
opportunity while you can--
finance jargon,
arbitrage opportunity,
to figure out what's
the best way to attract
more diverse talents.
You have more qualified
voices in the room.
So you're actually a step ahead.
I think this is why I sort
of-- you know, a lot of--
a lot of firms have
an opportunity,
a strategic opportunity,
to improve their labor pool
by just being more open
minded about who fits in
and just spending
the extra time.
Could we have found someone
better than C, G, and T?
Maybe.
They really good.
They're really good.
But I'll tell you,
the team fleshed out,
we had a Pakistani
guy join the team,
an Indian guy joined the
team, an Israeli woman
joined the team, and it was
a much more diverse group
very quickly on that basis.
We had a lot of other
things going on.
But I think a lot of what
we deal with in this space
is that people say--
all the firms we work with
were making a lot of money
before they started
focusing on diversity.
If you took away all the
storm, and fury, and fun
of diversity inclusion, most
these firms are making money.
The firms that actually
choose to go over the hump
and actually develop that talent
are doing one of two things.
They're paying lip service to
some issue that's out there,
or they've generally
said, this is good for us.
There's a business case here.
And I think-- I
generally believe
that there is a very clear
business case for it.
There are a lot of other things
going on behind the scenes.
Yes?
SPEAKER 1: Sorry to interrupt,
but we have five minutes left,
and I do want people to get
some time to ask questions.
So if that's OK with you, yeah.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: Yeah, so
the idea of this laundry list
was that we could
break at any time.
So by all means, please.
SPEAKER 1: Perfect.
So yeah, so like I said, we
have about five minutes for you
guys to ask any questions.
Thanks a lot for
the presentation.
I found it really interesting.
My one kicking off
question is you mentioned
law firms, investment
banking, traditional banking
are much further ahead than
tech companies and other,
so what lessons would
you say like a Google
or other companies that are at
the beginning of the journey
could take for the for
the more established ones?
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN:
The number one thing
I think is run
towards difference.
If you see something
that's different,
don't run at it
with a pitchfork.
Run at it with--
you know, run towards it.
Open yourself to it.
You know, I had an irascible
Turkish cab driver on the way
out to Heathrow this morning.
And he was-- he had a
lot of strong opinions
about a lot of stuff.
I didn't agree with a lot of it.
But I was really glad to have
that conversation, because I
learned a whole bunch
of stuff about Turkey,
and the situation there, and--
and he was he was a
little bit out there,
but I was ready to have
that conversation, because I
was going to learn something.
So you know, I
don't know how that
works in sort of
tech world per se,
because you have so
many different parts
of your business.
But I would say run
towards diversity.
Run towards difference,
and that's at all levels.
Internally, you know--
I think I was--
I had my eyes open
in particular.
I live in the space.
I work in the space.
I breathe and sleep
this, but I was still
myself you know, taken aback
the first time I met, you know,
a transgender person.
That was just different,
really different for me.
But how cool is that?
And I think if you sort of reach
out and sort of bring people
into the fold, you're
going to learn.
An institutional will
only learn from that,
and you're bringing in people
from other sectors that
are only going to add value.
It used to be in the
US Midwest years ago,
it used to be Swedes
versus Norwegians.
All right?
I mean this is--
there's all manner
of talent out there.
You just need to open
your minds to it.
And I think Google
is well on the way
from all the conversations
I have, frankly.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
I have a question
regarding your operations.
So if you started
like in the US,
and and then you
moved to the UK,
those two markets are
very much developed
because of apprenticeships
and graduate schemes.
So it's kind of--
I am not going to say it's easy.
But it's easy compared
to other markets
to you know, just get the
talent to recruit you know,
talented young people
from different backgrounds
and then get them into
the right companies.
Now, if you are now, you
know, expanding scale
throughout the
markets, you mentioned
Bogota, Kabul, I
don't know any others,
how do you want to start that?
How do you want to
shape it, because a lot
of those companies are not
prepared to get young guys
that, let's say, don't have
all the skills that need to be
trained in investment training.
How do you want
to approach this?
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN:
It's kind of-- it's
very straightforward in my mind.
You've defined-- the
victory conditions are
you need a small set
of sponsors, who are
willing to buy into the notion.
You don't need everybody.
Here it was five firms in 2000.
Now, it's 60 plus, a small
number of firms that get it
and a talent pool that you feel
you can access readily enough
and assemble enough paid
or volunteer support
to train them enough such
that your training makes
a difference.
So much of what is required to
succeed in a corporation has
to do with showing
up on time, you know,
dealing with feedback
as it comes, and not--
things that don't require a
huge amount of intervention.
And if you're able to
put together a training
program around
that particularly,
and you have a few
people who buy into that,
you've got a program.
I mean, the question of
sustainability and scale
comes in.
That's where you set
your victory conditions.
Do you want 10
firms or five firms?
Do you want them
contributing 1,000 euros
or 25,000 euros each?
I think just doing
the raw numbers,
our average sponsorship
across all of our firms
is just under 20,000 pounds.
I wouldn't expect that to be the
situation in day one in Kabul,
but certainly, in our Accra
program in Africa in Ghana,
that is operating in a much
smaller scale than we operate.
But they've got 60-something
kids going through that program
every year.
It's fantastic.
It's really fantastic.
So totally doable in
almost any market,
but it does have to be
modified to the country.
AUDIENCE: From one Jamaican
to another, you're welcome.
I have a question.
So just in relation to
countries like Jamaica where
your problem is education
is at the further end
of the spectrum.
You're thinking about basic
things like food and survival.
How do you then get countries
such as Jamaica and others
to that level
where they can even
see the importance of
education and moving
up the ladder in terms of
their career and so on?
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: OK, so there's
actually two answers to that.
One of them has to do with this
question of de-risking at risk.
This is not--
Google, it's not
clear to me, is going
to be institutionally
equipped, and I'm
happy to be told
otherwise, to take someone
on who has a long criminal
record with multiple drug
offenses or this, or
that, and the other.
Someone is not going
to make it no matter
how much you intervene, because
the resources to get someone up
that curve, to get
into that position,
it's just not effective.
And we're dealing with
profit-based companies
at the end of the day.
So there's sort of an 80-20
rule, and can you get--
with that 20% of effort, can
you get that 80% of impact.
And if you're going for people
who are generally struggling
at the ends of the Earth, that's
just a really hard problem
to solve.
And I'll be perfectly honest
and say SEO London doesn't
have the resources to do that.
We're not funded to do that.
That being said, I did try
and start up SEO in Jamaica
not too long ago,
probably about 2004.
We managed to get
Queenie, sorry,
we managed to get Q from a
really rough part of Kingston
to get a job at UBS in
New York, transforming
her potential at some point.
Ultimately, it
wasn't sustainable,
because the structure of
that-- that program had
structural issues, overly
reliant on the US visa
situation, as a first point.
But we had another effort.
We tried to make it an
indigenous effort, and we had--
and I'm forgetting
the gentleman's name.
He's a billionaire.
I should remember
billionaire's names.
But we had a Jamaican born
guy who lives in Canada,
and he owns a couple of the
banks and a few other things.
He came down, and
we sat in a room
with myself, him, and a
few other young Jamaican
entrepreneurs and
said, how can we
make this-- use this SEO model
and deploy it in Kingston.
And this guy said, I'll
give you half the money.
You guys got to go to the
rest of the world to fund it,
and I was living in London
at the time, and I was--
I wasn't going to be
doing this full time.
He was supplying half the funds.
I had to look at the rest of
the folks around the table.
They had to be willing.
They weren't willing by virtue
of they had other stuff to do.
It wasn't their
problem in their mind.
You know, it takes will.
This is a concept
whose time has come.
It's not hard to
copy and paste it.
The barriers to entry in that
sense are low as anything.
Anybody can set up a program.
You can even set up
a sustainable program
if your maintenance
levels are humble enough.
But it takes will, you know.
The only way we're able to do it
in London in the first instance
was I was willing.
I had a little bit of resource.
I had some credibility
in my profession,
and I had a list of about
20 American ex-pats running
around London who were bored
and looking for something to do
and were ultimately
were committed
to what we were doing, and we
were able to that back up that
effort.
So to do it in Jamaica, or
Puerto Rico, or wherever,
it's all doable.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
Thank you.
I've been told this
is the last question,
so I hope it's a good one.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN:
Maybe the best one.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
the best, exactly.
Thank you again for
your talk, brilliant.
You have talked about will
just there, and earlier,
you talked about how diversity
wasn't a theme back in 2000.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE]
and there is a lot
of different teams between them.
And so it's definitely something
that I've seen a Google.
Perhaps others
have seen at Google
in their different roles.
But how do you get will--
or how do you
inspire will, or get
people who are in the middle,
who are not in HR, for example,
but perhaps actually
high managers, leaders
within the business?
They are not C level.
They are not junior
high up, for example.
But they have the
potential to be--
make an impact on diversity.
But because there are
other priorities, targets,
business goals, and
so forth, it seems
like diversity or
inclusion gets pushed out.
But how do you get will
from the middle teams,
because from my
perspective, that's
where you can have
the biggest impact?
So if they make it, [INAUDIBLE]
it kind of cascades down.
So I'd be interested to get
you perspective on that.
ANDREW FAIRBAIRN: Yeah.
If I can rephrase the
question slightly,
it's how can folks who are sort
of mid-tier, in mid-career,
make impact and sort of drive
change in the organization
by raising attention to it?
It takes a tiny bit of courage.
I know so many people who are
in positions of influence that
are mid-career folks, who have
been able to walk into a room
and say, why can't
we do more of this?
Why can't we have--
if the topic is diversity,
or if the topic is Marmite,
why can't we do more of this?
It takes an ounce of political
courage inside the organization
to say--
to feel like, you're not going
to get kicked out the room
and lose your bonus check at
the end of the year for having--
trying to advance your
own agenda of this sort.
The firms that get
it right are the ones
that are open to those kinds of
conversations, where you're not
penalized for asking for some
sort of change around you.
But I tell you,
when people do it,
I know a fellow in
Boston, who he was-- he
had a role in recruiting.
He just-- he said,
listen, we need
to get more diversity
in this firm.
I'm going to make it happen.
He just went out
and just created
a cohort of diversity
in that organization
just by virtue of his
deliberate action and effort.
And he didn't get
penalized for it.
So he kept doing
it, and he said,
I'm going to keep doing it
until you tell me not to do it.
And now, there is
a whole, as I said,
cohort of talent that's
been given access
to that corporate world,
which are now splintered off
and gone to into 100 different
things over the years.
I mean, this is a long time ago.
But he had to have
the wherewithal
to just do that in
terms of inspiring it,
as opposed to putting
your own neck on the line,
because it's always clever to
have it be someone else's idea.
There are people all around
who are coming up the hard way,
many of them are invisible.
But many of them, if you
just probe just a little bit,
you'll find that they are
your strongest allies.
We were at a firm
not too long ago
and a senior partner in
real estate practice there--
I mean, real estate is
like tough as nails.
You guy think tech is hard.
Real estate, I mean,
that's a brutal business.
This guy is a partner at a major
law firm running that practice.
He broke down in
tears when talking
about how he had come up.
And what a great ally
to find and tap into.
If you start to know
the people-- the stories
of the people around
you, you're going
to find that not
everyone had it easy.
And if you can get
their stories out,
that's a way to have
the empathy and sympathy
that you need to them when
you bring your business
case forward and say
why this is a good idea.
You have support behind you, and
you don't bring just yourself
and your own neck on the
line, but you bring, you know,
a little bit more than
that to the table.
So yeah, I thought
it wasn't too random.
But I'm grateful for
the opportunity to talk.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks, Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]